one of my favorite books on working with
people changing behaviors is called
boundaries by dr. Henry cloud I read it
many many years ago and since then Henry
and I have become really good friends I
love Henry I love that book too and one
of the things I grasp from reading that
book and other books is this there is a
difference between forgiveness and
reconciliation those of us that are wise
in emotional maturity spiritual maturity
and those of us that are Christians are
called to forgive when you forgive you
set yourself free from the bondage of
the offense you're offended and when you
forgive when you're a victim and you
forgive you're not setting the
victimizer free you're setting yourself
free you can forgive someone and not be
reconciled to them then lady called a
minute ago and was trying to figure out
how to should she reconnect with her
brother-in-law she's having trouble
reconnecting to her brother-in-law after
he had affairs and everything else and
he supposedly come clean for the last
two years his wife has forgiven him and
taken him back and been reconciled to
him but not the sister-in-law she didn't
won't be around him so here's the
question at what point for someone's
misdeeds do you forgive them and then at
what point are you reconciled to them
they're different okay someone
rapes you what a horrible grotesque
violent unbelievably vile crime
I can't imagine can't imagine going say
something like that but to not forgive
them eventually as you begin to heal
from your emotional scars is to not set
yourself free from that very difficult
today I'm not saying it's easy but when
you let when you do forgive them you set
them free but you would not be
reconciled ever to someone who raped you
meaning you wouldn't go on a date with
them you know someone steals your wallet
you can forgive them but you're not
gonna you know leave your wallet with
them later your new wallet for them to
watch over your money you wouldn't be
reconciled with them probably ever in
that situation but in the case of that
young woman she was not personally
wronged her you know the guy's wife is
who was wronged right and her
sister-in-law was wronged her
brother-in-law I don't know how it
worked it was a brother-in-law but
anyway it was I think I guess her
husband's family as a way I understood
it but anyway the lady that the wife is
who was wronged she forgave and was
reconciled to the husband as he
supposedly is putting his life back
together I don't maybe I did he put his
life back together I don't know the guy
you don't know the guy well once you do
that you can always do a well you know
people that haven't done it can always
do it you know any one of you listening
is capable of adulterous affairs
everyone's capable of that and if you
think you're not capable of it you're
just about to have one I mean really
that's just ridiculous so at what point
do you forgive someone when they've done
something wrong at a distance like that
I can forgive him and you know I hope
he's turned it around and I'm not gonna
sit around and wring my hands and be mad
at him and worry about
I hope he's turned it around I hope he
doesn't hurt her again his wife I'm I
can I can do that now
at what point am I gonna trust this guy
again that's what reconciliation is at
what point am I gonna trust that his
conversion his turnaround is real see we
run into this all the time with our
coaching because a one spouse lies to
the other one about money what we call
financial infidelity your husband your
wife lied to you and ran up a bunch of
credit cards and you didn't even know it
it's hard to trust them again after that
now if you're gonna stay married you're
pretty well instantaneously gonna have
to sit down and go okay I forgive you
but I'm not necessarily going to be
reconciled to you financially I'm gonna
watch over your shoulder on everything
that's going on or we have a couple come
in and the guy is that is a you know
he's been found to be a gambling addict
which happens like every week
football betting is destroying families
finances it's unbelievable
so he comes in he's discovered she's
discovered he's a betting addict in the
online betting addict a gambling addict
and now he's gotten treatment he's in
Gamblers Anonymous and he's seeing his
pastor and he's seeing a counselor and
he's doing everything he's supposed to
do does that mean she just turns over
the checkbook to him and lets him go run
havoc again no no as a matter of fact we
recommend that when someone's recovering
from an addiction like that that they
not have control of they don't have any
access to money for a while until Trust
is rebuilt over time but 10 years later
trust should be rebuilt 10 months later
it should be better than it is now two
years later it should be better than
that it should progressively rebuild
trust
and so if 10 years later you you're
still you know you have not bet on a
football game again you've not lost any
money gambling again are you trustworthy
at that point yeah as much as anybody
else is and so we're not gonna treat you
like you have no ability to handle money
the rest of your life but for the short
term yeah
we're taking all access to money away
from you till you prove that you can
behave a little bit absolutely but then
gradually Trust is rebuilt and over time
it's rebuilt if you can not when someone
has on something like we're talking
about here has not when someone has
demonstrated over an extended period of
time that they're not entering into the
negative behavior and you can't forgive
them and you can't begin to trust them
in that area then it starts to be on you
in two years clean
if the guy's clean from his double life
adulterous Affairs or whatever he was
doing porn addiction whatever it was
suddenly it was all of that two years is
a long time
you should be some level of trust
rebuilt assuming it's all real now if
there's indicators it's not real if it
still looks like he's sneaking around if
he still got behaviors that make
everybody question whether this is real
then that's different but I'm assuming
this got straight and if he's straight
for two years then you know it starts to
be your problem if you can't begin to
trust at that point especially given
that his wife already has she might just
be an enabler
she might be she might be codependent
that could be what's going on could be
that he's cleaned up his life and you're
just a hurt you can't forgive see that's
the difference there's a difference in
forgiveness and reconciliation
they generally happen at different times
generally forgiveness should come faster
than reconciliation but if I pet a dog
and it bites me forgive the dog
I'm not petting that dog anymore we're
not gonna be reconciled with him this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]